okay here we go again over the last few
lectures we've been dealing specifically
with the mass spring system thought it
was a second-order linear homogeneous
differential equation we could of course
thought of it as a linear system in fact
we plotted the phase plane we were doing
exactly that looking at a linear system
now in the next few lectures we're going
to deal with more general linear systems
of differential equation these will be
very important when we go to nonlinear
systems linearization will be one of the
main tools that we'll use in any event
in this part of the course will
primarily be concerned with
two-dimensional autonomous linear
systems in fact two-dimensional constant
coefficient linear systems that is
linear systems of the form X prime is ax
plus B Y and Y prime is CX plus dy here
a b c and d are all constants now to
handle these linear systems we're gonna
have to make an excursion into the field
of mathematics known as linear algebra
now most people who've seen linear
algebra regard that as a field that is
basically concerned with solving linear
equations not at all with differential
equations but the fact is that when you
see the linear algebra come up in
differential equations you really see
geometrically why this field is so
important many of my students who've had
a little bit of linear algebra before
they take the differential equations
class come up and say wow yeah now I
understand why this topic or that topic
is important now as an aside note you
don't need to know any linear algebra to
understand this part of the course I'll
delve deeply into anything we need from
linear algebra as we go along so let's
begin with
say the matrix notation we're going to
need the concept of matrices and vectors
so let me review or or tell you what I
mean by matrix notation we're going to
take the system X prime is ax plus B Y
and Y prime equals CX plus dy and
abbreviate it using vector notation I'll
write the vector capital Y as the column
vector little X and little Y are
dependent variables and I'll also
introduce the coefficient matrix I'll
call it a capital a the matrix will be a
two-by-two matrix consists of a square
with four numbers in it the first row of
the coefficients of my first
differential equation so it's just a and
B and the second row of the matrix is
the coefficients of second equation C
and D so our 2x2 matrix a is given by a
b c d that's the way i'll enunciate a
matrix now we're gonna write our
differential equation as the vector y
prime is the matrix a times the vector Y
now what do I mean by matrix a times the
vector Y well to take the product of a 2
by 2 matrix ABCD and the vector little X
little Y what we do is take the dot
product of the first row of matrix with
our vector the dot product means I
multiply the first term a by X and add
to it the product of the second term B
with y so a B dot product with X Y gives
me ax plus B Y just the right-hand side
of my first differential equation and
then secondly take the dot product of
the second row with the vector X Y that
gives me CX plus dy as the second term
of the vector so all together what you
see is Y prime equals a Y is just the
vector that's the right-hand side
of the differential equation namely ax
plus B Y and CX plus dy and Y prime of
course means just the vector little X
prime little Y Prime
so that's vector notation for linear
systems as an example take the matrix
one two three four
what's the product of that matrix with
the vector say one minus one well we
just take the dot product of the first
row 1 2 with our vector 1 minus 1 that
gives us 1 times 1 plus 2 times minus 1
or minus 1 and then secondly take the
dot product of 3 4 with 1 minus 1 that
gives me 3 minus 4 or again minus 1 so
let's turn to an example of linear
system of differential equations let me
look at for example X prime is X plus y
and y prime is 3x minus y in matrix form
this is the linear system vector Y prime
is matrix 1 1 3 minus 1 times the vector
Y so where to begin as always we look
for equilibrium points
what's an equilibrium point for this
system of differential equations now
I'll just look at it clearly x equals 0
and y equals 0 is one equilibrium point
both of the right-hand sides of that
system of differential equations vanish
at the origin are there others well from
Equation 1 which in order to have
equation 1 vanish we need X to be equal
to minus y but then in equation 2
this says that 0 is equal to 3x that's
minus y so minus 3 y minus y equals 0 so
therefore y must be 0 but then from our
first equation X must be 0 so what we
have for this linear system is only one
equal
point at the origin now as a guide to
what's coming later noticed that for any
linear system X prime is ax plus B Y CX
plus dy that linear system always has an
equilibrium point at the origin we
always have an origin equilibrium point
the question that will come up later is
are there other equilibrium solutions in
this particular case the answer was no
the origin was our only equilibrium
point now what about other solutions for
this system of differential equations
well I claim that the solution Y of T
given by the vector e to the 2t e to the
2t is a solution I'll actually write
that by factoring out the e to the 2t
from the vector giving me e to the 2t
times the vector 1 1 by that I mean just
multiply each term by e to the 2t so I
claim that e to the 2t times the vector
1 1 is a solution we've got to check
that is that the case well let's see is
it true that that satisfies take the
derivative of e to the 2t e to the 2t
does that equal matrix 1 1 3 minus 1
times e to the 2t 1 1 well first term
differentiate e to the 2t that's our X
of T term we get 2 e to the 2t does that
equal X plus y yes both x and y or e to
the 2t so X prime does equal X plus y
second term that's e to the 2t that's
our Y of T term does that satisfy y
prime equals 3x minus y again the answer
is yes the derivative of e to the 2t is
2 e to the 2t and 3x minus y is 3 e to
the 2t minus e to the 2t again 2 e to
the 2t so we have a solution
now this is going to be a very important
solution this is what we call a straight
line solution look at this solution it's
e to the 2t times 1 e to the 2t times 1
the x and y components of this vector
are the same that is for each T this
solution lies along the straight line y
equals x in the plane it's a straight
line solution notice that x and y are
always positive e to the 2t is always
positive and as T gets large e to the 2t
gets very large so this solution runs
out to infinity along the line y equals
x on the other hand when T is negative e
to the 2t is small but positive and in
fact as T goes to minus infinity e to
the 2t goes to 0 so this is a straight
line solution that scoots along the line
y equals x out to infinity as time goes
on and down to the origin our
equilibrium point as time goes backwards
and then it's easy to check that as
we've seen for other linear differential
equations any constant times that
solution is also a solution so see e to
the 2t times 1 1 is also a solution to
this differential equation
now how about other solutions are there
other solutions for this differential
equation well here's another one let's
try the solution Y of T is given by e to
the minus 2t and minus 3 e to the minus
2t or as I did earlier let me pull out
eetu the minus 2t from that vector and
I'm left with e to the minus 2t times 1
minus 3 is that a solution again you
just have to check it quickly does the
first term X of T e to the minus 2t
satisfy the differential equation well
the derivative of e to the minus 2t is
minus 2 e to the minus 2t does that
equal X plus y
yes X is e to the minus 2t y is minus 3e
to the minus 2t so X plus y is minus 2 e
to the minus 2t that equals X Prime and
similarly you can check that minus 3 e
to the minus 2t our Y of T term also
satisfies that differential equation so
here we've got a second solution of this
differential equation and this solution
of the differential equation though lies
along a different straight line we look
at the y coordinate the y coordinate is
always minus three times the x
coordinate the y coordinate is minus
three e to the minus 2t the x coordinate
is e to the minus 2t so this is a
straight line solution lying along the
line y equals minus three x the line
through the origin with slope minus
three and now again we've got an e to
the minus 2t term here what happens to
this solution well the x coordinate is
always positive e to the minus 2t the y
coordinate minus three e to the minus 2t
is always negative so what happens as
time goes on we're on the negative part
of the line y is minus three x as time
goes on our exponential tends to zero so
this time the solution tends to leak
will be in point at the origin as time
goes on and as time goes backward it
shoots off to infinity a straight line
solution like the previous example only
it's going in the opposite direction and
again we have that any constant times
that solution is also a solution to the
differential equation so any constant
times e to the minus 2t times the vector
1 minus 3 is a solution to this
differential equation so let me go and
look at what these solutions look like
actually in the phase plane
so here is our matrix the matrix is 1 1
3 negative 1 and here are our two
straight line solutions we have one
straight line solution lying along the
line y equals x you look at the vector
field you see that the vector field is
pointing away from the origin along that
straight line solutions here are running
off to infinity as time goes on as time
goes backwards they're receding into the
origin
similarly we saw any constant times that
is a solution if I if I multiplied by
minus 1 I'd get the solution that lies
on the opposite side of the line y
equals x and again this solution as time
goes on runs off to infinity as time
goes backwards it tends in to the origin
and we also have another solution this
solution lying along the line y equals
minus 3x this solution now tends into
the origin as time goes on and tends
away from the origin off to infinity as
time goes backwards so in this
particular case we've got two straight
line solutions one leaving the origin
the other coming into the origin we're
gonna see as we delve into linear
algebra that those are the solutions
that give us everything before going
much further let me stop and talk about
the linearity principle given two
solutions say y1 and y2 of a linear
system then it's a fact that a constant
times y1 plus another constant times y 2
is also a solution of the linear system
ok we've already seen that if you have
one solution a constant time it is also
a solution it's easy to check that the
sum of two solutions is also a solution
so the linearity principle says that
you've got two solutions then you've
really got infinitely many solutions any
constant times the first plus a constant
times the second is a solution
to this system of differential equations
so that brings up two questions first
what are these other solutions look like
and then secondly when is this
combination of two solutions with a
general solution in the example we just
saw we found two solutions or I gave you
two solutions can I use those two to
manufacture the general solution well
first question is what do these
solutions look like
let's do for example the first system
the first solution rather remember that
was e to the 2t times vector 1 1 ok the
second one was e to the minus 2t times
vector 1 minus 3 what does the solution
that's the combination of these two
solutions look like what does any
constant times the first plus any other
constant times a second look like well
what happens as time goes to minus
infinity as time goes to minus infinity
that solution with an e to the 2t times
1 1 that solution gets smaller and
smaller it goes to 0 so that says that
the first term constant e to the 2t 1 1
sort of vanishes as time goes backwards
leaving us only with our second solution
e to the minus 2t times vector 1 minus 3
and also as time goes forward what
happens well as time goes forward the
exact opposite thing happens as time
goes forward the solution involving e to
the minus 2t now tends to 0
that leaves us essentially with only the
first solution a constant times e to the
2t times 1 1 so as time goes forward our
solutions look like one of the solutions
we found as time goes backward they look
like the other solution we found so
let's look and see what these other
solutions look like in the phase plane
so here we see our two straight line
solutions one again running away from
the origin
the other one tending into the origin if
I take any other solution notice what
happens in backward times it looks like
the straight line solution running along
the line y equals minus 3x in forward
time it looks like the other straight
line solution all solutions have that
property they look like one of the two
straight line solutions in forward time
and the other straight line solution in
backward time so here is the full phase
plane picture for this linear system of
differential equations two very special
solutions are straight line solutions
and then all other solutions looking
like the straight line solutions in the
far forward time or the far backward
time this is one of the many phase
planes that we're going to see for
linear systems of differential equations
this picture is what's known as a saddle
phase plane the origin is called a
saddle point so the question is is the
solution c1 e to the 2t 1 1 plus c2 e to
the minus 2t times 1 minus 3 our general
solution that is can we always find
values of c1 and c2 that allow us to
find the solution corresponding to any
initial value problem say the initial
value problem Y of 0 is the given vector
X 0 y 0 so plug 0 into that solution we
get c1 times e to the 0 1 1 plus c2 e to
the 0 times the vector 1 minus 3 2 those
two vectors add up to our given initial
condition X 0 y 0 that is can we solve
the equations c1 plus c2 equals x 0
that's the first component of our
equation the second is c1 minus 3 c2
equals y 0 here X 0 and y 0 are some
given constants any given real numbers
can we find c1 and c2
satisfy those equations so look at the
first equation the first equation says
that c1 is equal to X 0 minus c2 and
then the second equation says that c1 is
3 C 2 plus y 0 so we must have X minus 0
minus C 2 equal to 3 C 2 plus y 0 so
that says that X 0 minus y 0 is equal to
4 C 2 or C 2 is equal to X 0 minus y 0
over 4 so yes we can find a c2 that
works C 2 is just quantity X 0 minus y 0
divided by 4 and then plugging that into
the second equation we see that C 1 must
be equal to 3 C 2 plus y 0 or C 1 must
be equal to from what we saw earlier 3/4
times X 0 minus y 0 plus y 0 or C 1 is
3/4 X 0 plus 1/4 y 0 we've got it we can
find C 1 C 1 is given by that expression
in terms of X 0 and y 0 and C 2 is given
by the other expression so we have the
general solution to this system of
differential equations now we don't want
to be doing that algebra all the time
there's actually an easier way of seeing
that that's the general solution
remember at time 0 one of our solution
is at 1 1 whereas the other one is at 1
negative 3 think of those as two vectors
in the plane we've got to find a pair of
constants that multiply the vector 1 1
and the one vector 1 minus 3 and add up
to any vector in the plane say x0 y0 can
you do that geometrically well yeah just
look at that vector 1 1 and 1 minus 3 if
I stretch 1 1 out
and I squeezed one negative free a
little bit
I can arrange so that those squeezed
vectors and stretch vectors form parts
of a parallelogram whose diagonal is our
given point x0 y0 that is if i
strengthen the vector at 1:1 and and
compress the vector 1 -3 just the right
amount
I can arrange so that those vectors add
up to x0 y0 geometrically we see that
yes this we can find a c1 and c2 that
work we do have the general solution
that's a notion that's going to come up
over and over again I'll say that two
vectors are linearly independent in the
plane if they don't point along the same
straight line through the origin okay so
two vectors that point at some angle
that's not 180 or 0 degrees are linearly
independent whereas two vectors that
point in the same direction they're not
linearly independent they are dependent
or two vectors that point in the
opposite directions they're not linearly
independent and then the fact is that if
two vectors are linearly independent
then given any point whatsoever in the
plane say XY or call it the vector Z we
can always find a c1 and c2 that work
that is we can always find a c1 and c2
such that C 1 times the first plus c2
times the second adds up to the vector X
Y now that's pretty clear if our vector
V is the vector 1 0 in our vector W is
the vector 0 1 because then if the
vector Z is the point XY in the plane
all we have to do is multiply the vector
V by the number X and multiply the
vector W by the number Y and clearly we
end up with the sum XV + y W equal to Z
and in fact that's true as long as V and
W are linearly independent you can
always stretch or compress or flip
the vectors to the other side so that
the corresponding vectors will add up
exactly to your point XY if V points off
in the northeast direction and W points
off in the west direction and XY is
somewhere off in the northeast we can in
for example this picture just shrink V
and flip W to the other side and
manipulate it so that the sum of those
two vectors by the parallelogram rule
adds up exactly to XY so that gives us a
geometric technique for deciding when
we've got the general solution so one
more example let's look at the linear
system X prime is minus X and y prime is
X minus 2y matrix form its vector y
prime is minus 1 0 1 minus 2 again
equilibrium solutions clearly the first
equation says that X must be equal to 0
but then the second equation y prime is
X minus 2y says that y must be 0 so we
only have an equilibrium point at the
origin are there other solutions well
look at that first equation the first
equation is just X prime is minus X we
know a solution to that it's any
constant times e to the minus T and then
what's our second equation
well our second equation is y prime
equals x but we know what X is it's e to
the minus T ok say k1 e to the minus t
minus 2y our second equation is just a
first order linear non-homogeneous
equation y prime minus 2y plus k1 e to
the minus T and we know how to solve
that right the solution to the
homogeneous equation is just Y of T
equals some other constant times e to
the minus 2t and then our
non-homogeneous a solution to the
non-homogeneous equation is well we've
got Y prime equals minus 2y plus k1
- tea we'll just have to guess something
of the form a constant times e to the
minus T naught K 1 or K to some other
constant okay and in fact if you do the
math you'll see that that constant given
by K 1 that we had before actually works
the solution is X of T is K 1 e to the
minus T and Y of T is K 2 e to the minus
2t plus K 1 e to the minus T so there's
one solution to the differential
equation they we already have another
solution so our combination of solutions
by the linearity principle is that one
the first solution K 1 e to the minus T
1 1 plus the second solution K 2 e to
the minus 2t 0 1 is that the general
solution to this differential equation
well yes at time 0 we're at 1 1 and 0 1
in each case those vectors are linearly
independent we've got the general
solution
what are these solutions look like take
the first solution right say with k1
equals 0 and k2 equals 1 k2 equals 1
we've got you the solution e to the
minus 2t 0 1 that's the solution that's
a straight line solution lying along the
y axis X is always 0 Y is just e to the
minus 2t another straight line solution
ok and what about the second solution
well let's take the second solution to
be k1 equals 1 and K 2 equals 0 then we
get X of T is e to the minus T and Y of
T is e to the minus T also
so again X and y are the same another
straight line solution this time lying
along the line y equals x straight line
solution coming in to the origin along
that straight line so let me go
look at what this system looks like here
are our two straight-line solutions now
this straight line solution comes into
the origin and this straight line
solution also comes into the origin so
in this case all of our solutions tend
into the origin
we've got decaying exponential x' in our
general solution all solutions tend into
the origin a very different phase plane
from what we've seen before all
solutions here tend to the origin so
this now sort of opens up the question
of how do we proceed
well when to find the general solution
of systems of differential equations
what we'll do in the future is try to
find those straight-line solutions and
when we find those straight-line
solutions we'll be done in order to do
that we need some more tools from linear
algebra that's what we'll investigate in
the next lecture
[Music]
[Music]